I believe the quickest path to happiness
is accountability once you realize that
everything is your fault you actually
become happier attention is the number
one asset I love that people are being
more vulnerable today but I will say in
the growth of vulnerability we need
growth and accountability you know
people become very good at blaming mom
and dad for all their problems oh this
all sucks because my mom did this got it
let me do the work no no no no no no yes
comma you're a big boy now stop it I
always say watch what I do not what I
say say I Champion my parents but I'm a
human being there's things my parents
did that I think were M turns miscues I
never talk about those things I think
more people need to look at
accountability people are finally
looking to be a little more vulnerable
and things of that nature but I think
accountability is on the decline which
is leading to a lot of the unhappiness
in the world I believe the quickest path
to happiness is accountability once you
realize that everything is your fault
you actually become happier